hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment
breach while we're on our continual
quest to find new stuff in this game and
I didn't notice it
pardon me does somebody have a little
rumbly in there tumbly well I'm not for
eating not for Billy or anyone Billy
wants to get a little more friends hello
I got a key card and a cup which I can
you they did add a bunch of new sounds
in this game Oh welcome I like all the
new stuff in this game but I finally got
a key card which means that I'm gonna
able them be able to make Axl
scuse me pardon moi I could have sworn I
was this on the other side of that door
uh-oh what what no wait a minute what
that wasn't what is everybody breathing
me oh that's the things I just sound I
read up on the wiki after I met the guy
they're creepy as hell apparently they
repeat the last line of their last
victim I can't move you know banana
anymore
wait a minute what wait a minute what
huh you wanna run that by me again
did I just scoot forward uh Billy Billy
I hear you
this is an exact goddamn do click you
little bit of what ever happened before
I need that who put the button was right
was it ever was it please please push is
an activist
something with a bass violin is coming
after me too serious of duplicates no
it's a series of duplicates oh my god oh
it's an endless hallway forever
no that's really cool but also
disturbing how do I get out of here am I
just gonna be able to what whoa oh oh I
get you don't think that you can mess
with me five two smart no thank you
Billy you don't deserve to be here I'm
gonna this won't work look I failed
everybody laugh and watch me die all
right Billy
wanna come out there look at my hands in
the air no no kill me no no no no rip my
neck don't know us
so Mac seriously
bugger tits stop it oh I gotta go back
down I'm trapped up here there's nowhere
for me to go thank you
but at the same time no thank you
let's go visit our favorite friends
again why are my footfalls so loud
think I'd tone it back a few decibels
[ __ ] oh I fell down an elevator why am I
such an edge oh I'm alive
wait a minute what oh no dad okay
whatever then oh I'm gonna call you
Susan and you're gonna be my friend and
then I'm never ever ever ever gonna see
you again
there he is hi one of you Susan one of
you Sally
no I'm nothing I'm markiplier make
videos on YouTube I'm very handsome way
too handsome to eat no one only your
shadow haunting you but a run little
girl better run away the market is
coming to get you
SCP ma RK IV Li her eyes that even music
get out here no no no no no no no no all
go faster right now oh you do that again
ah never have to see you again in
another day my live what the hell is
that oh no no no no who's looking who's
making me look there
this isn't in the right monitor what are
you doing no no no I don't want to look
okay so I gotta get through here but I
know he's I in there right right here we
go gimme I'm totes mix screw it's fine
don't look at the monitor come on baby
brothers making good progress is the
important thing
let's keep rolling forward nothing can
kill ya if you keep movin that's a lie
it's all children aw crap yes ah oh I
think Billy is behind this door oh
that's okay I don't mind
he's not a little dude get out of your
low on you dickbag oh you bet on the
throw Yunel but i'm gonna come here
you're a douchebag that's the fumble
where the old man parson good what the
hell you call me huh I'm spying words
stretch okay this is gonna take a while
I got my omni card everybody is so proud
of me now because I'm such a cool dude
yeah I can get anywhere anywhere in the
whole world probably gonna be hell are
you ha the ring no the key the key that
was recently added Oh
when we can't the key unlock any doors
and then like the keys thing don't I no
need to do that no more because I got oh
it doesn't ah so that new key is
something completely different that I
actually don't know yet so I gotta find
that out and I may have kill myself by
picking the DA who knows ah the ring yes
I thought I wasn't supposed to be here
because you don't know what pick it up
oh you're on full drop you know you're
that yeah not again Billy
oh god Abbi you're still here piston
ball
you know I can't possibly be to Billy's
her old man was gonna be too old he's
your dad
okay I'm gonna just move on because I
think you may have respawn there wait a
minute we go not having a fun time here
ah gotcha
found ya all right now I can finally
make it sorry I'm sorry what did I do
I just thought I saw a flash flashing
yellow eyes are you gonna be you gonna
be like that huh you're gonna be like
that
I'm ready for you I'm ready for all you
got don't think that you oh god damn it
ha I'm ready for you
I'm ready yeah that's all right I saved
down here cuz I'm a badass and you're
all [ __ ]
so I maybe you should get out here it's
not being such giant [ __ ] Oh zombies
well good good I wouldn't have it any
other way
on/off switch let's throw that on for no
reason I'm sure that did nothing bad
hello Doctor how are you doing I'm not a
nurse for you to shut up
laughing hey Lee didn't quite catch that
you were speaking gibberish elevator
power feed generator can't carry any
more items doctor is gonna F right off
to hell and back
nananana na nananana nananana I can't
see anything
not today not today
well come on let's come in right around
the corner organ is Lee no oh oh we
shove it oh he's good
oh oh oh just don't go
um
hi
how are you I'm good
I how's the kids family ah oh no you're
way too coffee here to go hook it hugs
gonna punch get it
I'll just gotta get out of here I'm
gonna [ __ ] out here pretend like that's
what you say say to me huh
tough words for a guy stares longingly
into my eyes
that was weird I was probably weirdest
moment I've ever had in this game for
some reason he didn't want to touch me
oh no oh my god
ah no no looking right at him Oh No yeah
you did
skirt Nelson still pretty disturbing all
right our turn
they said they updated the face
detection on this sumbitch so um good it
actually is now liver not looking not
looking oh look at this
such a nice thing whatever I did there
oh that was cool too gonna look this way
don't hear any screams of the Damned get
risk saving now let me know when I bump
into a big bulbous gangly freak there's
a big bulbous gang-raping oh oh he was
right there oh he was right there okay
okay come on live a normal long life
what's turn in any faces am I in the
clear least nowhere heard of this one
nowhere but it's an open door to nowhere
excuse me oh please what Oh Billy no no
Billy really that seems highly unlikely
Billy always loves to play oh good it's
this thing wait a minute I remember this
thing I made the wrong choice before I
tried to kill him Billy right
I'm busy Billy don't dick with me don't
dick with me Billy yeah whatever bring
it on if you want to bring it open I
don't care hello Helene oh god why oh
really
I'm sorry I made an accident on the
floor I'm gonna have to come back later
sorry sorry about that one excuse me
why that's a Phillies out that's not
Billy Billy oh I'm such an idiot
I turned to look for the old man how
long has I've been playing this game I'm
a dumbass
I know go sleaze I know I'm very
attractive you're where
Billy are you doing Billy Zen Moses
never doubted what do you think Bernie
know what's who's summoner know who are
you well you there we go no no no no no
no oh god no no no dude you are so
freaking creepy it doesn't even make any
sense
oh you guys easy no no no no no no no
like you you man what
what is squishing my situation I don't
even know how you get there no no no no
no no no oh no no no hello ducky where
is this lead all the maintenance oh I
got it yeah I should go this way you're
right
you're always right now god damn it old
man I don't have time for your [ __ ]
um okay well down Oh God I just make a
big circle
oh it's nine-tailed Fox about to enter
the facility I'd be lovely
no no no who are you
you okay you all right buddy you look
good
okay what's gonna leave now anybody here
hello
okay that was a creepy thing Billy you
down there
yep you down there I'm not going down
there oh it's bright and shiny in here
oh yeah what's a [ __ ] suck
what
was what
oh okay oh really loud okay
oh please stop please stop
oh you oh okay thank you thank you for
stopping hello you aren't you just
adorable
could you well up what are you doing
come on Eric
I'm oh I'm not Eric my name is
markiplier what what's going on here now
oh this is gonna be fun well then oh hey
can't get through this okay no no oh I'm
I'm innocent my hands are in the air I'm
totally okay I think that's enough SCP
containment reach for me for one day I
think I've subjected myself to enough
horrors for your guys's entertainment so
thank you all so much for watching I
love this game they keep adding new
stuff there's something in my eye and
yet it's still terrifying and still free
that's amazing so if you want to see
more SCP containment breach there's link
in the description below also giant
horror games playlist lots of scary
stuff annotations everywhere thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
surprise [ __ ] be channels on
YouTube like that make Mercure over
there PCC one that would let's draw
channel hello everybody my name is
markiplier